ottawa o dosh ano já chegaram para a
apresentação
nós vamos pensar na sua biografia
pessoal ou estamos aqui hoje para falar
um pouco as nossas peças e informa que
vai ou não nas nossas vidas e na vida da
cidade e depois fomos parar para mim não
esteja a nossa espécie a nível
profissional maravilhosa que está em
causa é um pouco por causa do nazismo e
também fazer construir as nossas para
fazer a inspeção os avós as nossas
ideias e fumar a nossa própria é
exatamente o que encontramos um porto
enfrenta não só vou esperar sempre
tivemos viva ao emigrar mas podemos
dizer com tantas outras pessoas se
encontram nessa situação mas muito
porque me dá maior eficiência no final
passamos lá fora mas muito porque
encontramos um corpo em frança é um
porta estava muito encantadas mais
ligado ao turismo é no mínimo a gente
sabe que desde 2005 quando a inédita
taça enquanto importa que o 3 no chão
novamente a uma maneira será 111 humano
e adaptando a essa é a convicção que nós
precisamos é o primeiro avião
nesse âmbito está concluindo as parcelas
não desperta no porte é muito curioso
porque isso vamos ajudar um mapa nós
como a quinta e já tem estado bastante
irá influenciar no bar x porque somos
quase obrigados em descanso por desafios
na cidade mas que engraçado é que eu ia
falar das coisas não fala muito com o
paulo tem quase um feito à escala
internacional tenta que as pessoas muito
acima das outras chegadas da europa que
incluiu está um pouquinho stone
turística quando é que começa em
curiosamente no entanto encontrava em
uma guia turística o 'porto em meu
marido tivesse eu acho que o problema
responsável é o cultivo em francês como
cache nesta série b está muito curiosa
a portuguesa é impressionante é que nem
sempre no rio sem ar
como é que isto turismo também comercial
do porto é mista
um guia turístico em 2008 mais louvável
e quase 11 línguas maneira muito mais 11
anos do porto que é um pequeno livro com
várias cidades francesas e comércio
local que vem aquecer a casa trabalho
trabalho na tevê uma votação quase mil
edifícios e construir vai substituir a
imagem que quer uma encomenda de mariah
e cannon
foi um choque com as pessoas na altura
construiu sua extensão dos danos
a questão e cole que ia e que está nos
registros como é difícil viver é em
antigamente no mesmo lance vai dar é
difícil quase não vê que é uma raça é
everton está integrado na malha de
assinar no forno
isso é uma coisa que nos faz refletir no
desenvolvimento das nossas ideias tem
muita importância para nós conseguimos
perceber como é que as pessoas encaram
atualidade forma que isso foi no meio do
gol e novamente estamos nós acreditamos
que haverá uma mudança mais rápida e
parece um tempo levam vários locais e
com os pontos da cidade que de alguma
maneira estamos posso fazer o papel
ingrato está uma maneira podem vir a
sofrer novas interessante porque não
exatamente esse aumento nos prêmios de
risco não só por causa do conselho todas
aquelas que conseguirem ver o fmi 1910
falar em português que é completamente
diferente
além disso aí tem coisa muito curiosas
como as cidades periféricas
não não tem interesse nenhum em dizer
que ele não acreditava aumentar sua
atuação na copa nós é porque nós é muito
curiosa porque por esta situação são
bento também levantamos não testa
realmente influenciou mais trabalho que
estávamos a explorar na altura e que são
bento nós sempre acreditamos que era uma
votação sobre o plano integrado na
cidade fazer parte da marca histórica
dos anos quando a 1910 era manual 28 em
reunião com a cidade que tinha vindo a
destruir uma zona tão bonita da cidade
para tentar uma olhar para as ruínas
histórico um mês algumas corridas
passando temporariamente podem receber
ao que modifica a visão que temos
problemas para vencer os espaços
impresso
o espaço será o interessante é que seja
no mínimo integral na cidade
desta forma o desafio que nos foi
mandado nós
a esposa nesta ruína mesmo assim ambos
já começa em 30 anos
a ideia passa a desempenhar o benefício
a cozinhar aquilo que existiu enquanto
varela alvenaria dentro da cidade com
todos ainda se caracterizar o espaço que
existe para a cidade que é ruim é
daquelas casas apresentaram mais partida
para a aventura do do ponto chic mãe
contou essa história toda nós passamos
um belo comentário muito simples um
sentido e nós não somos um instante ele
passa então por criar uma onça que o
livro digital dando origem àquela que
nós chamamos hoje de rosa que é um jeito
que eu devia não nos causa muita gente
porque eu estava saindo da escola da
cidade e que nosso cartão de visita irá
realizar e que tem muita fé quase com
uma máquina digital temporária é capaz é
só uma ruína como constroem um espaço
com história que é difícil nessa tabela
esse tipo de atitude é exatamente com
essa aquilo que nós estamos em que quer
seja uma crítica que não gosto e que
gostam desse tipo que todo esse lance
que nós fizemos obras é esse espaço é
que o que nos deixa mais suporte técnico
né não
a cidade que já fizeram várias
intervenções esta também é uma ideia
busca que nós comentar considerando as
obras passaria mas também à noite
a nova faixa com as duas empresas que
quisessem nem sempre é nossa mensagem
pagava passado minutos mas é bastante
tempo
não gostei de tudo assim mostramos no
xaxim lançou alguns dos docs to move
nessas questões todas a isso que estamos
a trabalhar muito com a cidade no caso
quem está lá é impossível e eticamente
numa escala do tempo muitas coisas vão
ser só vão ser feitas em tamanho quem as
observa no tempo que estamos também
vamos assimilando as maneiras enfrentou
estamos à altura ou não e passou longo
tempo israel teremos outros temas também
estamos no centro hospitalar e que
fizemos um pouco um trabalho nesse
sentido é que estão atualizando empresas
nesse caso a sua vez mais direitos que
não estão em pânico nas pessoas chança
joão
criamos também um caro a fazer é
explorar nada como é tradição pode ser
vista no fim de outra maneira muito mais
absorvente e quase que através do olfato
eliza e ela este movimento de montanhas
e quero quase não está com medo da rua
que se fosse um trançado em entrevista
esta sensação diferença está quase nessa
numa história dessas montanhas do mais
direitos
é exatamente o que nós cantamos pedro
clemente dos santos que é difícil
trabalhar em chegarmos ao que como nós
podemos abandonar gerir as emoções das
pessoas quando confrontados com as
nossas ideias ou com a espécie que nós
achamos que era tradição toda a cidade
uma porque estamos fazendo é exatamente
olhando pra isso que nós tivemos uma
idéia de que não então antes nós só nos
encanta as pessoas a trabalharem melhor
é a saber a redução que a peça traz a
perspectiva negativa não é não é isso
que está em questão é mesmo por que não
então vocações do nosso papel é e acho
que elas mesmas quando confrontados com
a cidade com os planos da cidade
isso é uma outra ideia que foi também
comentado portanto salientou na zona
não sabemos ainda muito porque não tinha
um teto também temos e produtos locais e
então a idéia é exatamente essa né não
construir uma ideia que as pessoas
pudessem 200 militares que assim vê e
não digo que não há qualquer um nós já o
fez na rua olha a multa não olha costa
lá dentro uma conversa foi 2010
atendendo proposta desta vez que as
pessoas possam assumir elementos das
respectivas mas amanhã com alguma
estranheza também refletidas ano criado
pelas respectivas no pavimento
os outros carros sendo muito de santo e
basicamente é uma malta publicação por
cada uma explica assim mesmo envolvendo
ou não com com esta peça né esse é o
nosso propósito três anos bom três
escalas
nós gostamos muito trabalhar em cima não
importa ainda mais a escrever
trabalhasse na cidade de moda com as
histórias que trabalhar em escala depois
da transmissão também uma coisa é
assumidamente muito forte
depois o próprio pessoal a tentar
dirigir de maneira que é não façamos
nossas vitórias emoções das pessoas é é
ensinar aquilo que estamos a apresentar
amanhã